I am the first one to have ever played
this game before you are in great luck
this game is gonna be so [ __ ] good
you can tell just by looking at it oh my
[ __ ] god I am so excited to play this
game I'm sure that everyone who played
this game is playing it because they
think it's a really good game and not
because it's gonna get a lot of clips
from YouTube because of the title of the
game and you tell me right now that is
not a copy of me they're using my
likeness for these [ __ ] [ __ ] how do
they even get away with you these
youtubers in the title why are they
boring the gameplay what is it some
[ __ ] board is looking at a new game
please finally I've made it I am the
most popular youtuber this game is
plagiarizing it's been a long hard trip
know it I just uploaded some videos and
people watched it it's not that big a
deal
alright well let's say create PewDiePie
now that's I don't have to change
anything just need to change the eye
color and I have a beard now so
personality well that one that one no
not that one and that one and that one
and that one okay we're gonna do a
gameplay video what the [ __ ] is this
alright what should we call the video
big-ass booty sex tape PewDiePie okay
there we are making the gameplay what am
i doing I'm choosing reactions okay
unfunny comment
[ __ ] yo game what are you trying to tell
me here all right so we have to edit the
video okay let's add some coloring and
outside a funny title there oh boy this
is gonna be a great video acting
what are you telling me here this is the
life of a youtuber right here it's
pretty much it in a nutshell okay we can
sell out except in order for at least
okay sell out is definitely a huge part
of being a youtuber we're gonna play
giant soccer start a video we're gonna
do a game plain god this game is boring
me to death go make the video what am i
doing to the game [ __ ] kissing it
come on game please I need the feels no
one's covered gorilla soccer - yes this
is gonna be a great one this is gonna be
the winner insane gorilla takes bath of
brofist with me okay that's it hey we
got six subscribers 24 reviews Oh get
the [ __ ] out mom abyss is staring at my
closet school called me and you missed a
lot of classes [ __ ] you mom I'm gonna be
a youtuber one day man we can look at
the comments I love watching this game
play I can't believe that a
self-proclaimed youtuber is this bad at
editing take some classes for the sake
of your own user Allison you're a piece
of [ __ ] [ __ ] you what are you wearing
you look like trash League of Giants
done
okay another tighter I'm not a title how
do you do titles oh I get it you just
put it high in there
got it this will surely get a lot of use
make an unfunny comment boom look I'm
Jack septic a daddy why ever not made
any money yet I've been doing YouTube
for years where's that [ __ ] money
okay so now time is passing we made two
dollars [ __ ] yeah we made two dollars I
got depressed I am this game really is
realistic what a [ __ ] am i doing just
walking in to stare at the corner
I think it's more fun than doing this
[ __ ] come on Peter pie come out of there
you got to make another video dude come
on Porter pie you got to make another
video like every [ __ ] day come on man
come on buddy oh that's it I know you
need that money
you [ __ ] greedy little [ __ ] oh look
at him forcing a smile yeah let's make a
happy expression there you go those
idiots they bought it
another happy expression oh my god let's
force out a funny comment nailed it okay
we got some comments if you don't know
how to record videos properly you should
be a youtuber that's how it is
but that [ __ ] you got 40 likes on that
[ __ ] Oh forty lakhs on that
[ __ ] 42 [ __ ] you that's right
[ __ ] it's like that [ __ ]
mom mom was that you again I hate your
mom you didn't understand me
I got more views than your mom shut up
others on your game okay okay we're
playing this horror game let's let's
give a murderous look that always works
that's a classic Peter pie cellar right
there
okay let's make an off topic comment I
got a haircut today what do you guys
think is it so good you guys like it the
self realization of what a piece of [ __ ]
you are while playing this game alright
we can promote this video okay we can
self advertise alright let's let's do
that hi guys
no you got a tricking you got a trick
I'm like it's an actual comment great
video really watched watch all of it
honestly by the way check out my channel
and subscribe please need more subs
thing you very much
boom mine YouTube life is easy this is
some straight-up [ __ ] you're losing
subscribers
oh god Red Alert red alert what do we do
we're losing some oh god make a new
video make a new video fast we got to
make a new video flash whatever we got
whatever broken words got it I'll make
another video I'll make 50 videos I
don't give a [ __ ] just crank that [ __ ]
out there ya go
you ungrateful son of a [ __ ] alright
okay alright hello wait let's do it
singing comment I am what you say that
you only meant well let's do a
professional comment oh wow the graphics
in this game looks very cool the 1080p
resolution it's just wow man I am so
good at making videos this [ __ ] does
itself let's just do this is how you
edit where's my next paycheck thank you
very much
where's the option to randomly yell at
the sit at the camera ah where's the
option to be fake scared what the [ __ ]
this guy is not gonna go anyway
this guy is clearly an amateur okay we
can decorate our desk um yeah what can
we do buy the cheapest thing what's that
a lava lamp that's pretty cool [ __ ] we
fail our grades Mama's gonna be so
pissed once she's done staring at them
oh my god she teleported what is she
doing
no mom no no mom what are you doing I'm
gonna lose so many subscribers mom no
this is my mom even know that that's not
the actual computer
but a dumb [ __ ] okay we got to make a
new video fast before we lose any more
subscribers hundred was one flawless
gameplay let's add some copyrighted
music haha I would never do that [ __ ]
that's unethical man oh boy this is
gonna be a long video if the video is
more than 10 minutes we're gonna make
double Adsense come on drag out the
outro make the outro longer make the
outro another 50 minutes oh my god the
video quality is up the roof I'm up
there now with the big youtubers
greetings are you Felix Kjellberg I
heard your record videos could you
record a video game and upload it I'll
send you the game free game absolutely
hundred likes boom that's a new record
[ __ ] yeah I'm the best youtuber in the
world oh I got a new game horrifying
sewers no one has ever played horrifying
sewers this is the new horror game
that's gonna bring my channel to new
levels we got off loaded fast [ __ ] the
quality [ __ ] the content it's gotta go
up fast scariest game ever scared of
holy [ __ ]
died the peed a little BAM that's a
title alright we're gonna start off with
some copyrighted music get it roll like
a get a [ __ ] okay murderous look damn
nailed it okay we got to make a serious
kind of while this game looks really
cool I am so into this
alright let's pretend we're happy
playing it no [ __ ] that of this Megan
murderous look
works every time those fangirls are
going crazy this is my greatest video
this is my best video I've ever made
I'm so proud oh [ __ ] we got a copyright
strike not this [ __ ] again I don't want
to deal with this [ __ ] look how sad
I am look I sad you tubers made me I'm a
sad sad man this is the truth ban
YouTube we're all depressed why would
anyone want to become a youtuber for the
fame for the money for the mom yelling
at you look at me look at where I am
look at my shitty content what's the
worth it I don't know I've gotten so
many views but at the same time I'm
Beauty pie you know what I mean
just feel dirty I used to be so young
and innocent look at me now look at me
now you don't want to be a youtuber get
a real job I don't want to do this [ __ ]
anymore I quit I can't quit how do I
quit I'm deleting this game and I'm
deleting my channel I said dirty I'm
dirty and disgusting I can't do this
[ __ ] anymore I'm out [ __ ] you [ __ ]
everyone I'm going back to selling hot
dogs now you know how it works now
before al this game wasn't as bad as I
thought it would be I don't know if it's
my type of game but it was fun to check
out leave a like if you enjoyed watching
and now you know all my secrets so I
guess I really should just quit I think
for all youtubers can agree on that it's
it's a lot of work it's really stressful
but we do it because we love it a lot of
people seem to see YouTube as a way to
get famous or get money just make videos
because you enjoy making them that's my
number one tip from number one hypocrite
see you later my little clay sorry okay
um stay awesome brush okay we will go
with Evan SS semester five pawns cuz he
needs to wake up and kill himself
why are you so mean